kim kardashian her favorite hobby other
than dating these sort of
meth-head-looking people from saturday
night live her favorite hobby
is trying to spring criminals from
prison she loves it this is one of the
things that really harmed the trump
administration is that the trump
administration which was brought to
power on really popular issues get tough
on crime get tough on the border bring
some
sense and stability back to our country
well he ended up pushing this jailbreak
bill and he did it in large part because
of the advocacy of people like kim
kardashian
who say well these poor people who were
in prison they were unfairly convicted
or even so their sentence was too harsh
even if they did the crime so kim
kardashian recently has gone
too far apparently even for her and her
handlers she's been trying to get texas
governor greg abbott to stop the
execution of a mother who brutally beat
and murdered her two-year-old daughter
so this mother her name is melissa lucio
she pled guilty to the crime and kim
kardashian said no it was a false
confession
she didn't really do it
melissa lucio's daughter mariah
was found
dead
and she had
a weeks-old broken arm the arm had been
broken for weeks but no one had treated
it she had bite marks on her body she
had patches of hair missing
and
so the mother was arrested for kill oh
and when the mother was arrested by the
way
she was asked how did the how did the
little girl die and the mother said she
fell down the stairs this is the oldest
line in the book for people who abused
their spouses and abused their families
it fell down the stairs and that's what
kim kardashian was pushing
then by the way they did an examination
of how the girl died she didn't die from
falling down the stairs she died from
blunt force trauma
melissa lucio had 13 other kids who were
not in particularly great shape either
and this poor little girl was killed and
now kim kardashian
begging begging
to free this woman obviously she should
not be
but kardashian's not alone here
the the real issue with the katanji
jackson confirmation is this issue
and i'm not even just talking about
child abuse because katanji had this
this weird history of letting child
rapists and and pedophiles off the hook
it's this issue of always taking the
side of the criminal to the neglect of
the victim that the criminal must always
have been done wrong by society and what
we need to do is just let them off the
hook reduce sentences let them out of
jail abolish prisons if we can defund
the police that's the problem that's
what they say
now obviously that premise is not
right
but it's a premise that totally pervades
the left it gets back to that question
tom cotton asked he said you you judge
jackson you spent your whole sentencing
here talking about how sorry you felt
for the perpetrator of the crime do you
feel any sorrow for the victim or no
you're only taking the criminal side
and it just gets to down to a
fundamental view of how we how we see
the world
do you believe that that men are perfect
we're born perfect there's no original
sin and the only way we're corrupted is
by society and society how society got
corrupted that's another question and
society is so broken and these poor
criminals they're put upon they never
had a chance and we've got to we've got
to be really good to them we've got to
give them a second third fourth 75th
127th chance
or
do men have some corruption in their
hearts is this a broken world and is the
best way to deal with that corruption to
to pursue justice real justice for
victims and for the criminals by the way
to help reform their ways which is it
which is are we going to end up with
utopia if we just tweak a few more laws
or do we need to perpetually deal with
crime and pursue justice the latter is
the conservative point of view the
former is the liberal point of view it's
pushed by kim kardashian and judge
jackson and everyone in between we've
got a kardashian on the court now when
we're talking about our basic premises
of criminal justice
one one ought to pray for our country
with with that kind of point of view on
the court right now go to
hunterdouglas.com
knowles i did not realize this
before i got my house in nashville and
really started to take a little more
care into the way i was living to you
know no longer living on a pile of
magazines on the floor but actually
taking care about the beauty of my home
windows and window treatments
i think they might be the single most
important thing in your home because it
determines how the light comes in it it
totally shapes how you live in your home
hunter douglas has incredible designs
gorgeous fabrics control systems so
advanced they can be scheduled to
automatically adjust to their optimal
position throughout the day as the sun
moves through the sky it's incredible
the shades diffuse the harsh sunlight
they cast this beautiful glow across the
room it's phenomenal take my word for it
right now go to hunter douglas make your
home beautiful that's hunterdouglas.com
slash nols head over there today get
your free style get smarter design guide
with fresh takes creative ideas and
smart solutions for dressing your
windows hunterdouglas.com
knowles for your free design guide
i'm glad you like that clip now
ring the bell subscribe make sure you
get the notifications also head on over
to apple podcast but if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]